[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an episode called adhd
is necessary from a sci-fi drama
anthology on children spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
in the future the government wants only
genius citizens to live in their country
for this they implant an embryo in all
women the mothers are given the
responsibility to raise the children to
become an a-grade student if a child
gets good grades he and his mother are
given an apartment in an exclusive
complex such mothers are also awarded a
glowing pin for their contribution to
society the ones who do not get good
grades have to live in slums called the
pigeon cage at the beginning of the
movie a mother is being implanted with a
new embryo after the process she is
handed a guidebook on how to raise the
embryo she is asked to follow the
guidelines properly yang chuan is the
top mother who has raised the best
student they have ever had named ruo g
unfortunately he was killed in an
accident some years ago following that
she was implanted with a second embryo
and gave birth to nova currently she is
at a ceremony being awarded for her book
on how a mother can help their children
get good grades chuan is considered the
best mother by many a woman in the
audience asks her the secret to raising
a grade children the question takes
chuan by surprise so she remains silent
the presenter claims that the question
is personal so she wouldn't have to
answer it it is clear that chuan is
hiding something somewhere else the
higher officials of the state are
discussing the surge in the number of
narcoleptic children such children are
taken to the advancement programs and
killed by the state declaring them as
faulty embryos researcher yi shion
notices that all the students suffering
from sleep disorders have scored less
than the minimum standard he puts two
and two together and finds out that the
students who score low are being falsely
diagnosed so the state could get rid of
them when he confronts his superiors
about the matter they falsely accuse him
of running an underground rebellious
organization against the state he is
soon arrested chuan is with her daughter
walking to their apartment after the
program alongside them the students with
low scores and their mothers are being
taken somewhere by the guards suddenly a
woman comes running to them yelling that
the students will be killed they panic
and refuse to go with the guards as the
crowd gets bigger they start to run away
creating chaos amidst it chuan's scarf
falls to the floor after the commotion
ends nova offers to wash the scarf on
her way to the bathroom the researcher
yee shan's mother ling na recognizes
nova as chuan's daughter she seems to
know something about chuan but doesn't
reveal it to the girl she simply hands
her a keychain and says that it is a
gift from her late older brother a
confused nova returns to her mother and
finds her watching the news on a big
screen it says that yi sean was going
against the state and its system so he
was executed his mother has also been
removed from the list of top mothers
because of his deeds nova recognizes the
woman as the person who gave her the key
ring however she doesn't tell her mother
about the encounter at home nova's tutor
teaches her about the first cloning
process for her upcoming exams nova is
not as diligent as her older brother
which worries chuan she wants her
daughter to score a plus at any cost
because if she doesn't they will have to
give up all of their privileges moreover
she is considered the best mother in the
city so her daughter not getting good
grades is humiliating for her after the
class the tutor frankly tells her that
he thinks nova will not pass the test
since her grades have been falling every
year one of the lights in schwan's top
mother pin goes out she thinks that it
is because of a technical problem but
the tutor explains that the lights go
off when one's kid doesn't perform well
since chuan's children had always had
the best grades until now she didn't
know about the feature the light
embarrasses her so she wears a scarf to
hide it following her meeting with the
tutor she brings nova to the pigeon cage
where all the people with low grades
live she wants her daughter to get a
taste of the life she will have if she
isn't good at studies in her heart chuan
knows that she doesn't care about her
child she is only worried about the
humiliation she will face if she has to
leave the apartment complex the
following day chuan has to go grocery
shopping embarrassed by her pin she
tries to put it down but it blares an
alarm telling her that she should wear
it everywhere she goes she efficiently
hides it with a scarf and goes to the
store but a woman sees it nonetheless
she asks chuan if her daughter is
getting good grades chuan openly lies
and says that nova is doing better than
ever upon returning home she witnesses a
woman getting kicked out of the
apartment complex because of her son's
grades she blames her son for not being
good enough the woman had been living in
luxury for the past 15 years but now she
has to make a life in the slums juan
holds her pin tightly seeing that she
could go through the same thing in the
near future later she monitors nova
giving a test through her tablet nova is
visibly struggling to answer questions
which worries chuan even more soon the
second light in her pin also goes off
now she has only three lights to go
before she has to leave the apartment
and give up her privileges the next day
at school nova acts strange she keeps on
fidgeting with her pen and books when
the person behind her asks her not to
move so much she lashes out at him even
when the teacher asks her to not be rude
she tells him his class is boring
everyone is surprised at her behavior
because she is usually very gentle and
nice the next day juan brings her to the
hospital to get her checked she is
diagnosed with adhd the doctor claims
that the stress of exams might have been
the cause of the disorder he warns chuan
to take good care of her daughter
because if the syndrome gets worse she
might go into depression and become
suicidal the following day at school
nova accidentally hits her teacher on
the leg while sweeping the floor she
doesn't apologize for her mistake and
instead tells him he should watch where
he is going the conversation escalates
quickly and the teacher holds her arm
asking her to apologize nova runs away
and threatens to jump off the building
she is stopped by her classmate ki zhang
at the last second chuan simply brings
her home and serves her dinner it is
then revealed that chuan has asked nova
to pretend to have adhd so they can use
it as an excuse to avoid the upcoming
exams chuan says she is proud of her for
her believable acting the next day is
nova's birthday chuan wants her to
destroy all the presents that her
classmates give her nova is reluctant
because she doesn't want to hurt her
friends but chuan persuades her to bring
a razor to school at school nova's
friends wish her a happy birthday she
knows what she has to do but she cannot
bring herself to hurt them chuan watches
her on a laptop as she puts the razor
away and gently opens her presents
following that ki zhang and nova talk
about her weird behavior yesterday she
claims that she was just nervous because
of the test kijang asks her if she is
being pressured by her mother but she
claims that her mother is very helpful
and she would never pressure her upon
reaching home nova apologizes to her
mother she doesn't want to pretend to
have adhd anymore and claims that she
will study hard to get good grades
instead later at night she shows her
mother the key ring that the strange
woman had given her in the bathroom
chuan is shocked to see it but doesn't
reveal its significance she simply asks
her daughter to continue studying a
flashback shows us that the key ring was
handmade by her late son ruoji as a
birthday present for her but she asked
him to stop making such absurd things
and focus on his studies back in the
present nova starts to study harder than
ever and stops pretending to have adhd
one day she is again approached by the
same old woman lingna she has found out
about nova's adhd diagnosis and asks her
if she really has it or was it her
mother's plan she reveals that according
to the guidebook the students with adhd
are considered defective embryos they
are sent to an advancement program where
they are secretly killed if a student
gets bad grades both he and his mother
are sent to the slums however if the
students have defects like adhd they are
sent to advancement programs and the
mothers can still enjoy their privileges
chuan has been urging nova to pretend
not to keep her away from her exams but
because she wants to keep her privileges
even if it is at the cost of her
daughter's life nova is in disbelief
furthermore she is informed that her
brother ruoji's death was not an
accident she argues that he was the best
student nationwide so that cannot be
possible later that day she reads the
article about ruoji's death and finds
out he was hit by a truck she then goes
to meet the truck driver who claims he
was manipulated by her mother to take
the blame nova finally realizes that her
mother was behind his death the
following day she asks ki zhang if he
knows about the advancement program that
kills people he asks her to be quiet
because talking about it is illegal ki
zhang lives in the slums so he knows
everything about the state's unfair
program chuan sees them talking through
the surveillance cameras and goes to
meet kijang the next day she asks him to
stay away from her daughter but kijang's
mother stands up for her son claiming
that he can talk to whoever he wants
after finding out she will soon be sent
to the advancement program nova runs
away from home and goes to kijang's
house his mother brings her to a secret
tunnel that leads them to a camp of
survivors of the advancement program it
was established by ling na after her
son's execution she believes that every
kid has something they are good at and
grades don't define their worth hence
she has established this place to give
those kids an opportunity to do whatever
they enjoy everyone at the camp is nice
to nova but she feels like she is
betraying her mother by staying here
when no one is looking she leaves them a
message and runs away in the message she
expresses her gratitude to them and
promises to not tell others about the
camp when she reaches home chuan simply
asks her to eat her dinner nova
apologizes for letting her down and
promises to study even harder she asks
her mother if she loves her but chuan
doesn't answer her question later nova
is in the shower when suddenly she feels
dizzy she falls to the ground and drags
herself out when she opens her eyes she
finds herself in a hospital bed she has
declared a faulty embryo and sent to the
advancement program to be executed in
the following scene we see chuan being
implanted with another embryo when she
wakes up after the implant she finds
herself in the tunnel that leads to the
survivor camp lingna asks her if she is
happy after killing two of her children
she claims that her third one will grow
to be the same chuan still doesn't back
down and asserts that she has won this
war she returns home and gets to keep
the apartment along with all her
privileges she even writes a book about
losing two children and further profits
off of it a flashback shows us that
ruoji wanted to be a carpenter but
schwann didn't support his dream he
eventually got depressed which led to
his death
she also informs the police about
lingnaw's secret camp getting all of the
students arrested in the end she is in
an interview to promote her new book she
looks into the camera and says that if
you really want something to happen
there is always a way
that was inspirational subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching